I got of vasectomy due to climate grief
now I'm compelled to let plan we just
talked about this on the voice cast what
do you think I I mean the natural
logical conclusion is if you are so
worried about human impact on climate
you kill yourself right if you really
care right like isn't that like okay
well you know if you want to get a
vasectomy I can do you one further right
it's crazy I mean these people are
mental they're they're their brains have
been so destroyed with uh this like
anxiety and fear about the future like
you
know civiliz humanity is not the type of
thing you want to bet against like there
that kind of always finds a way you know
like everybody's like oh my God we're
doomed like this doomeris I it's
probably
existed forever there's never and you
know and yet here we are so I don't know
what what do you think about it for
about a year and a half I'd been
offering to get a vasectomy to do more
than just talk about how the world
didn't need any more humans in and
around our old Nova Scotia house i'
periodically make that horizontal Civ
scior mime to reiterate my offer news of
rising temperatures on the kitchen radio
finger snip Atlantic Ocean looking more
and more Disturbed finger snip even back
then in 2007 the North Atlantic
hurricane season was intensified due to
climate change snip
snip Daryl my then partner called out
from a few rows back in a crowded flight
we'd originally been seated together but
relocated so a mom could sit with her
kids when I look back over the packed
seats amidst the Roar of burning engines
she smiled at me and minded a scissor
cut with two fingers yes she finally
said in a Gest gesture understandable
only to me my then partner called out
this sounds like a guy who did and now
is no longer with the person who yeah
also an interesting thing here because
this is an ultimate in virtue signaling
obviously to say like I'm saving the
planet by not reproducing and then they
insisted on including no but they
insisted on it's interesting they insist
on including which is unnecessary that
they were not they were sitting
separately because they had to give up
their seats so a mother could sit with
their
child like that's like a weird thing
you're like okay you didn't have to say
that other than you just have to be the
best the best human possible and
everybody else who's reading this is
just scum that's part of why it was so
thrilling when my now wife Gizelle Vol
voluntarily mentioned not wanting kids
on our first date three years later we
got married and moved in a kind of
working honeymoon to sweaty equatorial
Singapore admittedly our next four years
of travel around Asia made us more a
part of the climate crisis problem than
the
solution basically I decided to carbon
offset my destructive selfish Lifestyle
by not propagating my own DNA and
instead traveled the world th this is
like a borderline onion article yeah
from not that long ago and it's but this
is the CBC this is this is Canadian
broadcasting this is government funded
uh propaganda right here did you see I
came up with this idea of toxic
compassion do you read my little uh no I
haven't seen that all right so uh toxic
compassion is the prioriti ization of
short-term emotional Comfort over
everything else over truth reality
actual long-term outcomes flourishing
everything it optimizes for looking good
rather than doing good people would
rather claim that body fat has no
bearing on health and mortality outcomes
to avoid making overweight individuals
feel upset even if this causes them to
literally die sooner or have a worse
quality of life people would rather say
that children growing up in single
parent households suffer no worse
outcomes than those from two parent
homes even if this misleads parents
children and teachers about why kids
behave the way they do campaigners would
soon shout defund the police as a
response to what they perceive as unfair
treatment of criminals even if this
results in more crimes being committed
against people from those minority
backgrounds due to the abandonment of
police officers from those areas so it's
people that say what they think sounds
good but ultimately might net a negative
outcome and Peterson said it's the
prioritization of short-term emotional
Comfort over long-term thriving it's
going to hurt now but the consequences
longterm are positive yeah you just
don't want to hurt anybody's feelings
but you disregard what the actual
long-term outcome is the same as with
this yeah bloke yeah yeah yeah I mean of
course I'm actually just listening right
now to um uh Jonathan height the codling
of the American mind and and they talk
about like he's he's talking about like
all the safetyism stuff where
essentially it has these actual uh like
negative outcomes you know because some
kid got like abducted in like the 70s
and then they like
essentially um were were clamping down
so hard on kids that it actually made
them worse off you know because you just
you don't let them go outside and
because like you know obviously it's
tragic that a kid got abducted or
whatever there was actually he talks
about I can't even believe this I had to
look it up yesterday in 2015 in Missouri
this family in order to teach their
six-year-old a lesson about not going
with strangers abducted him and like
renditioned him and from like a mall and
they put like a bag on his head and then
they like a mock execution like
basically basically like the craziest
lesson you could ever imagine and then
this trauma is going to teach you not to
let it happen again yeah don't go home
with strangers or whatever and like I
don't even think he did like I don't
think there was an in they just abducted
him to kind of teach him this lesson uh
you know kind of get ahead of it
preemptively well that's the [__]
horseshoe of like helicopter parenting
that it comes back around to just super
extreme mistreatment of your kid yeah in
the guys of you know I'm helping them
you're like this kid is going to have
this trauma for the one the other side
that's like oh yeah my kid will be fine
it's like it's the same idea my kid will
be fine my kid will be fine with me mock
[__] abducting him yeah from this
thing but there's no shortage of those
kids who who were like yeah my parents
worked and you know I had a lot of
autonomy and I was fine I was I seemed
to be okay I was fine maybe I got a
little bit of trouble but you see the
stuff about uh peanut allergies the
increase in peanut that was that was
another one in Jonathan I thing was
because they it like tripled the amount
of peanut allergies because they removed
peanuts yeah so uh if you grow up in a
household that that has a washing
machine like a dishwasher that doubles
your chances of asthma and if you grow
up in a house that has a dog it halfs
your chances of asthma because you just
get exposed to dirt so basically you
double and then you double again the
chances of it why the dishwasher
dishwasher presumably just cleans en so
in such a sterile way that you don't get
the tiny little doses of germs and the
same for dogs dogs coming in and out
bringing dirt in like playing in the
grass Etc um so yeah there's just ways
where you can sterilize the environment
so much that instead of it making kids
and people safer what it does is creates
such a protected environment that there
is nowhere that they never deal with any
kind of discomfort and this is
culturally
ideologically psychologically mentally
emotionally the exact same thing we see
with toxic compassion yeah I mean I'm
waiting for the shoe to drop on uh hand
sanitizer being bad for you you think
there's so many things we me and Ryan
were just talking about it how all the
stuff that used to be bad for you is now
good for you like remember I don't know
if but like my mom was very much even
still she doesn't come around to you
know she like you got to eat breakfast
you have to eat breakfast it's like you
you'll die you'll have if you don't eat
breakfast now everybody's like don't eat
breakfast or it's like you got to eat
now everybody's like fasting like you
know it's all the stuff it's it's
literally Bro Science has beat down mom
science and uh mom science is just kind
of reeling but uh it just I don't know I
won't be surprised if it'll be something
similar with the hand sanitizer where
they go people are hand sanitizing too
much and it's causing a rise and what
down stream from that yeah well we we've
been doing these meet and greets after
the show uh which is really great but
you do realize that like if if anybody
of these 600 people that have just shook
hands and taken a photo and like hugged
or like you know like slap five with if
any of them it's like I've just got I
got it all we did get Co all of us got
Co separately James in Australia Luke in
the UK me in Austin we all got Co about
two months before the show at the tour
began and we were like tour antibodies
like [__] yeah like we've done it I'm
going to be immune immediately went on
tour and just got wrecked by like other
like different viruses that yeah yeah I
mean that's that's kind of the nature of
uh of how it goes but yeah I don't know
it's unavoidable like I was I was just
on the train over here one thing I I
still find so difficult to understand is
couples where one's masked and one's
not because surely the one that's
unmasked will then give you whatever
you're trying to avoid right like am I
missing
something but I see it all the time
you're like a couple where one's
masked but like how you're gonna get in
the same bed tonight yeah like you're
GNA kiss later
so I I I don't know I don't know maybe
there's someone who's way smarter than
me who can explain that to me cuz I I
see it all the time like I saw it
literally just on the train right over
here in other news this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
and it is the best way that I have
started my morning every single day for
over 3 years now it contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium with no
sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other junk your
adenosine system that caffeine acts on
isn't active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system so if
you want to be more awake want to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
have better brain health this is the way
to start your day head to drink LM
nt.com
mowis to get a free sample pack of all
eight flavors with your first box plus
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it 100%
risk-free that's drink L
mn.com slod wisdom thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
then press here for the full podcast
episode go on press it